now it is true that for this
self-consciousness the essence is
neither and other than itself nor the
pure abstraction of the eye but an eye
which has the other naswinger self
though in the form of thought so that in
its other 'no sit has directly returned
into itself yeah at the same time this
its essence is only an abstract essence
the freedom of self consciousness is
indifferent to natural existence and has
therefore let this equally go free the
reflection is a two-fold one freedom and
thought has only pure thought as its
truth the truth lacking in the fullness
of life hence freedom and thought to is
only the notion of freedom not the
living reality of freedom itself for the
essence of that freedom is at first only
thinking in general the form as such a
thought which is turned away from the
independence of things and returned into
itself
but since individuality in its activity
should show itself to be alive
or in its thinking should grasp the
living world as a system of thought
there would have to be present in
thought itself a content for that
individuality in the one case a content
of what is good and in the other of what
is true in order that what is an object
for consciousness should contain no
other ingredient whatever except the
notion which is the essence but here the
notion as an abstraction cuts itself off
from the multiplicity of things and thus
has no content in its own self but the
one that is given to it consciousness
does indeed destroy the content as an
alien immediacy when it thinks it but
the notion is a determinant notion and
this determinist of the notion is the
alien element which it has within it
stoicism therefore was perplexed than it
was asked what for what was called a
criterion of truth as such that is
strictly speaking for a content of
thought itself to the question what is
true good and true it again gave for
answer the content less thought the true
and the good shall consist in
reasonableness but this self-identity of
is again only the pure form in which
nothing is determined the true and the
good wisdom and virtue of the general
terms beyond which stoicism cannot get
our therefore in a general way no doubt
uplifting but since they cannot in fact
produce any expansion of the content
they soon become tedious
moving into paragraph 200 we are now
getting to see some of Hegel's
criticisms of stoicism as a
philosophical stance and really not just
as a philosophical school but as a
moment in the development of human
consciousness we're getting to see his
criticisms coming to life stoicism is
going to be a very important step but
it's not going to be fully adequate to
what the human being and indeed if we
want to use a particular adeana that's
absolutely central here the freedom of
the human being it is going to require
Hegel is going to say as he has said
already in the earlier para rest that
the notion the concept the begin of
freedom is being developed through
stoicism there is a positive advance
that is taking place here but here in
this section he is going to say it's
only a notion and whatever he says it's
just a notion there's a kind of
abstraction going on to be merely a
notion means that that something hasn't
developed as far as it should so he says
now it is true that for this
self-consciousness that is the stoic
right the essence is neither and other
than itself nor the pure abstraction of
the eye so two different extremes have
been not necessarily rejected but it at
least worked past right the stomach is
not just going to be the eyes the pure
eye that we've seen in previous sections
nor is the stomach going to be related
to other Ness to alterity in a purely
extrinsic way as Hegel says this is an
eye this has the the force the
negativity of the pure
the capacity to be otherwise right with
other nests in itself they've the main
problem with this is that it is in the
form of thought so that's both the
positive to it right it's in the form of
thought we can think it but it's also
the negative in that it's only thought
it's not it really engaged with life you
notice that I've got a lot in life split
off from each other here and that's
what's happening in this passage that's
why Hegel is criticizing stoicism so he
says in its other nests it has directly
returned into itself this is always a
good thing for Hegel yeah at the same
time this its essence is only an
abstract essence it's not yet made
determinate it's not yet made concrete
so he says the freedom of self
consciousness is indifferent to natural
existence that's what's over here on the
side of life natural existence naturally
design is actually what's being said
here so you know design can mean
existence I wouldn't read a Haida
gariand design into it quite yet here
but it is on the side of the natural
that the world that confronts us the
human being has managed to stand in her
from that through you know the
master-slave dialectic through work
through desire the human being is
something different than merely the
field of natural objects yet at the same
time the human being at least for the
stoic perspective is going to be one
part of nature remember the Stoics one
of their key goals is to have one's
moral choice or however we want to
translate prior racist ones commitment
one's way of life in accordance with
nature that nature is in nature dripping
red with tooth and claw the way that you
know so-called naturalist wanted to
imagine nature that's really just an
imaginary but nature has the most
fully-developed way for human being
to to exist so if this speaking mirror
the abstract is not going to be good
he says the freedom of self
consciousness is indifferent to natural
existence and is therefore love is
equally go free the stoic actually lets
a lot of things go free this is actually
one of the things to recommend stoicism
we see the stoic saying well if this is
going to be a problem for you let it go
you know if depending on what they call
external appearances Fantasia
you know if doing that sort of thing is
going to cause you trouble let them go
because you don't really have control
over it anyway so the stoic is willing
to necessarily give up but but let go of
things and he says freedom and thoughts
however has only pure thought as its
truth this is where we get to the crux
of the problem with stoicism thought
wants to think more than just itself
because when it does think just itself
it lacks content this is going to be a
major problematic as we're going to see
not just for this section but running
throughout the entire phenomenology and
indeed Hegel's philosophy as a whole we
always have to have some sort of
determinacy some sort of you know real
existence to grapple with otherwise our
ideas and sort of losing their moorings
and even worse they don't they don't
grip things out there they it becomes a
kind of imaginary show by itself
so he says freedom of thought lacks the
fullness of life freedom and athough is
only the notion of freedom now usually
when we see notion be grab we're
thinking okay that's really good we've
got concept
thinking going on here but this is one
of those places where Hegel is saying
look the concept hasn't been worked
through quite enough in stoicism we
don't have the fullness of life the and
that's something that we want in this
this freedom that we are thinking we are
reflecting upon right as if we imagine
ourselves with Stoics what we want is
really the living reality of freedom
he's going to say he says it's the only
the notion of freedom not the living
reality of freedom itself by the way the
living reality of freedom itself we
could oppose that to the notion rights a
lot of times people say well if you're
if you're thinking about it you're not
really being spontaneous you're not
really acting there are cases where
freedom in the sense of you know pure
spontaneity there really isn't any pure
spontaneity but spontaneity is reacting
to the circumstances in front of one one
in a creative way that can't be opposed
to over thinking - - you know reflecting
too much - thinking things in such a way
that you never really get to act right
but there are also ways of acting and
thinking where the two interviews with
each other you know if you think about
many of the things that matter most to
us in life we we really do need to think
them through particularly in the complex
situations that we live in today and
even in Hegel this time so he says the
essence of that freedom is at first only
thinking in general the form is such of
thought which has turned away from the
independence of things that's that's
what stoicism wanted to do the things
are independent I can't control them I
don't want to get my effectivity tied up
with them I also don't want to have my
beliefs even too tied up with that
because that's what's going
drive me nuts it's going to aggravate me
I'm not clocking and stowing way here
but it's really what stoicism was about
how not to be aggravated by all the
content that surrounds you constantly
that's a Monica to put stoicism so you
know if we retreat to the site of the
thought that looks like a possible
solution but it's not really a solution
because it leaves this up it doesn't
grapple them with the world that just
sort of leaves it be honey so he says
why does this become a problem it's
turned away from the independence of
things and returned into itself when it
returns them to itself it's returning as
an independent thing but it's also
returning as he says as an individuality
how do I know what I am if I'm not
engaging with my environment if I'm not
engaging with that which is not me I
mean I can sort of postulate the other
within myself and live in an imaginary
world where I have conversations with
people who are about me but there's
something kind of think about that right
that's not really engaging with the
other or with all tyranny or with the
whole world out there or even a portion
of the world that could interest me that
gets rather stale that doesn't it
doesn't provide what we really want that
that essentiality that we saw so
important in them earlier passages so he
says since individuality and its
activity should show itself to be alive
the stoic can't just be a thinker the
stoic also has to be a living being not
a living being just in the sense of
eating drinking
perhaps copulating you know desiring
that sort of thing living in the sense
of you know we've seen a life talked
about in multiple ways life reflected
into itself life and living thought like
he says we won the living reality of
freedom we don't just want an abstract
freedom we want a living kind of freedom
yeah he goes on and he says there would
have to be present in thought itself a
content for that individuality so you
look at it as what thought wants is is
out there on this side or we could think
about this moment of other nests within
itself that other nests within itself is
where the world has its gripping points
that's why the world can aggravate us
maybe stomachs right but it's also where
we encounter the world and thereby
encounter our own selves so we can't
really know ourselves for Hegel in
isolation from everything else that's
out there so he goes on and he says
there's a content for that individuality
that content is given here in one case a
content of what is good and the other
what is true in order that what is an
object for consciousness should contain
no other ingredient whatever accept the
notion which is the essence the stoic
and not just the start but that really
anybody who is trying to grasp what is
essential about human consciousness and
its engagement with what is not just
human consciousness but gets taken in by
human consciousness you notice that
Hegel uses these two terms here the good
and the true
stoicism focused very much on both of
these it was not just focused on you
know some people present stoicism as if
it was just practical philosophy don't
have to worry about anything theoretical
just get down to brass tacks all you got
to do is read Epictetus as discourses as
opposed to the enchiridion and see that
that's totally mistaken Epictetus
knew his theoretical philosophy brings
it up sometimes but he's oriented toward
practical towards the good but the true
and the good are two different
modalities that connect up with each
other that have to do with what it is
that we're grasping here and what it is
that we're grasping about ourselves so
they become you know this this criterion
as as we see Hegel's criticism here is
that the Stoics don't really manage to
give this any determinate content and
notions like goodness and untruth and on
this side just being abstractions but
what they want is some sort of
determinacy for this so he goes on he
says here the notion as an abstraction
cuts itself off from the multiplicity of
things the the life the living
environment right and thus has no
content in its own self but one that is
given to it here's another interesting
observation if you try to abstract
totally kaolin say from everything you
know you know doing what we might say is
sort of a pure epistemology you know or
we're just thinking about the knowing
subject without any any sort of
determinacy of its own some sort of
determinacy will always slip in this is
by the way something that critical
theory you know which is very influenced
by Hegel brought up every time that
you're engaging in some sort of I'm
philosophizing about human being and
such you're almost always smuggling in
some content that that is conditioned
that you're not realizing so it's not
really human being as such the pure I
the transcendental you know unity of
perception or something like that that
you're dealing with you're dealing with
that but that is coming along with some
baggage right so Hegel says here
consciousness does indeed destroy the
content as an alien immediacy
thinks thinking is powerful when we
think something we change we transform
it in the process into thought right but
the notion is a determinate notion and
this determinist of the notion it is the
alien element which inhabitant of this
other mnestheus other two two same words
here meaning the same thing two
different words meeting the same thing
they're really the same in a different
way right and this is being taken in
this other this but it's not being
accurately thought out right so he says
stemis ism was perplexed when it when it
was asked for what it called a criterion
of truth as such strictly speaking for a
content of thought itself to the
question here we get to the very heart
of the criticism to the question what is
good or what is true stoicism
had to give an answer that didn't really
answer the question and it didn't just
ants not answer the question because
there was a kind of circularity there it
didn't answer the question because it
doesn't provide that sort of you know
vital essential gripping point where we
say yes that's it
so the question what is the good or what
is the true
stoicism who gives the answer like he
says here content less thought the true
and the good shall consist in
reasonableness for note-for-note of T
kite right being rational being
reasonable now that seems to give us
some sort of criterion all right but is
it a criterion that's really going to
satisfy us do we know what full
rationality is this is actually
something Hegel doesn't talk
but this the Stoics themselves have a
lot to say to them they don't think
we're totally rational that's an
achievement that we have to work out
over time but he says this self-identity
of thought is again only the pure form
in which nothing is determined so you
know let me read the last part and I'll
come back some final reflections it says
the true of the good wisdom and virtue
the general term is beyond which
stoicism cannot get our therefore in a
general way uplifting or up building
right we know that that's never good
what Hegel says that you know he's
always sort of a backhanded compliment
well that's very uplifting but it's not
providing us with any sort of scientific
understanding of what is low on what is
good or what is true he says they cannot
in fact produce any expansion of the
content they can't tell us anything
about stuff they soon become tedious
notice the appeal of their to what we
might call an aesthetic category it's
not just that they're untrue it's that
they don't they don't move us stomachs
ism by its own nature can be very
exciting at first but then Hegel would
say it becomes boring it becomes more
and more of the same you should think
back to the part of the preface where
hitting on was talking about the the
black night in which all cows are black
or you know painting with you know one
color or just two colors rather than the
whole little spectrum the challenge for
a Jungian philosophy is to do justice to
this side
and to do justice to this side at the
same time and not let anything go now
where we're going to come back to you in
thinking out you know where this is
going
Hegel is saying the stoic really can
only you know have a sort of bifurcated
position either they can think of
themselves in the abstract in which case
you know there isn't any determinant
content to the good of the true but that
sounds awfully interesting at least at
first and it's really just thought
itself right empties thought order that
he can accept some sort of determinate
content coming in there in which case
they can actually say some things are
are good and true maybe even they can
say that they're rational that's where
this sort of living world a system of
thought comes in this is where a lot of
Stoics really were but then it seems as
if there's a kind of arbitrariness or a
kind of impurity it's not pure thought
anymore some some determinacy some
individuality has crept in and maybe
what's valid for me and that respect
won't be valid for you or for the other
person is a stoic so this is a problem
for stoicism
the thinking consciousness as determined
in the form of abstract freedom is thus
only the incomplete negation of other
nests
from existence only into itself it has
not there achieved its consummation is
absolute negation of that existence the
content it is true only counts as
thought but also as thought that is that
is determinate and at the same time
determinate nest as such
section 201 is going to bring to a close
Hegel's criticism of Stoicism
and it's going to do somebody by saying
something really quite interesting
namely that the content that is not
being adequately negative eyes you might
say what could we'll come back to that
in a moment not adequately negated it's
somehow creeping back into the side of
abstract freedom or if you like the pure
thought the pure thinking the pure
willing of the rational subject the
stomach how is it doing it well it's
doing so by being thought right so when
I negate something when I say I am NOT
my property that somebody could steal
for me and which is going to make me
unhappy if I get identify myself with my
property if I desire my property as a
stoic I'm gonna withdraw from that and
say I'm not my property because that's
not in my power typical you know stoic
movement there I'm thinking it right I
am still connected with my property now
in the way of negation yeah insofar as
I'm doing that Hegel is saying that
what's going on here is that this is
determinate and it's also determinacy
itself it's Bush Timmons right and
Michigan tight so what does that mean
what that means that I can't really
negate things totally at least not at
this stage maybe we can do it later on
in the next stage which is going to be
scepticism maybe that can pull it off
but the stoic can't because the stoic
even though they put themselves out
there as if they
are totally distanced from everything
none of that bothers them Hegel seems to
think that there's always a bit of
thinking about that stuff not
necessarily thinking in the sense of
imagining or putting together you know
arguments about it but it could in turn
be having feelings about it even a
feeling of rejecting it that's always
still going on Hegel says so when we
look at what accesory says the thinking
consciousness as determined in the form
of the abstract freedom is the only
incomplete negation of other than what
is the other nests that he's talking
about there well the other nests can be
the whole field of life and we've seen
that's been a counter position that you
know against thought for for this whole
section on stoicism it could also be the
right the other person in whatever since
we understand that and other person not
the self they can also be the self
it could be one's own determinacy
because we've seen that itself
constitutes somewhat of a problem for
the stoic who is trying to withdraw into
this abstract freedom this I can I can
be distanced from I can disentangle
myself from anything that is not
rational anything that is not true
anything that is not good in order that
you have the criteria for that we saw
the previous paragraph we have to have
some determinacy this is a real pickle
here isn't it
so he says withdrawn from existence only
into itself right that's that's what
it's trying to do return into itself to
withdraw from existence it is not there
achieved its consummation as absolute
negation of that existence the existence
is still out there it's still it's not
just that it's still out there we should
also keep in mind
Hegel's stress in this
intersection how things exercise an
influence on us they they become
essential for us in the sense of having
importance for us this is not very well
or it explicitly worked out here but I
think that's something that you can make
cases is going on in his criticism so
this whole range of other nasarah t
we're not able as stomachs in this shape
of consciousness to adequately negate it
because we don't find enough on this
other side so like he says the content
it is true only counts as thought the
stomach can withdraw and turn the
content all this stuff into just a lot
but also is thought that is determinate
and at the same time determinate this is
such when we come to what I began with
in talking about this passage this is
not everything that Hegel has to say
about stoicism but this is where he's
now ready to shift to the next attempt
to deal with this that is skepticism
you